When I was younger, I was much shier and I
was really fortunate to have these teachers
in my life who saw something in me and brought
it forward.
They saw that there was a light there, but
it was hidden by a lot of obstacles.
I think it was probably as early as seven
or eight that I was really committed to being
a comedian.
I had very vivid dreams about performing standup
comedy . . . and I really couldn’t hear
what I was talking about, but I could see
myself as an adult, getting huge responses,
getting a lot of laughter and applause.
And there was just a real sense of this was
my destiny and I know that I am this.
So I started out my career at 14.
I started doing comedy at school.
I was attending a high school for performing
arts, and, for me, my main obstacle was probably
shyness.
And I had an English teacher who would pass
a notebook between us -- and it was very silent
-- and I would write in it, and he would critique
it in the margins.
And it was always very positive critiques
and really beautiful encouragement.
He was somebody that I trusted very much.
He was a gay man who was rather flamboyant
for my school.
And even though it was San Francisco, it was
still, you know, this was in the ‘80’s,
so it was still… it was tough for him, I
think.
And one day he didn’t come to school, and
it was really alarming to me.
And I held the notebook, and he had written
in the margins, “You’re such a good writer.
Just never stop writing.”
And “never stop writing” was in such big
bold red letters.
Finally, I went to this class and there was
all these boys in the class and they were
laughing.
And I got closer to them and one of them said,
“That faggot got killed.”
And it turns out that my teacher had been
murdered by an act of homophobic violence.
And it was so heartbreaking to me, yet, from
that day and from then on, I always remember
that he said, “never stop writing.”
And this is something that I live by and that
I will never stop because, you know, he brought
that out in me and then he was gone.
And it reminded me of the immediacy of life
and the necessity of living your life and
living it because it can be gone in a moment.
And so I feel that that’s the best advice
I’ve ever gotten and the best mentor I’ve
ever had.
And it’s a very simple, simple thing: whatever
you’re doing, just don’t stop.
Just never stop.